sleep is the fundamental layer of mental
and physical health if there's one thing
that we should all be doing is working
toward sleeping long enough and deeply
enough 80 is a good goal because things
happen until you are sleeping long
enough and deeply enough 80 of the
nights of your life there are a number
of risks to not getting enough sleep
deficits and learning deficits in the
immune system reduction in testosterone
and estrogen in both men and women so
disruption hormones disruption of gut
microbiome the severity of those things
depends on a lot of other things too
prior Health other health conditions
context age occupation you know if
you're not getting enough sleep in your
high-rise construction worker definitely
if you're an office worker we need to
sleep enough now what's enough sleep
enough sleep has been argued in six
hours other people it's seven hours
other people it's eight hours it's
basically waking up without an alarm
clock and feeling rested insomnia is a
medical term and insomnia is essentially
diagnosed as falling asleep during the
middle of the day due to lack of sleep
at night time wow okay many people who
are having trouble sleeping at night are
not falling asleep during the middle of
the day they're dealing with grogginess
or crankiness or other effects of having
fragmented sleep need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Dr Andrew huberman and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
what are the main causes of not being
able to fall asleep is it rumination is
it traumas that you're holding on to is
its arguments is it
self-doubt or insecurities is it you nap
too much is it the foods you ate too
late like what would you say are the
main causes
of not being able to fall asleep all of
the above
but the the primary one is a failure to
turn off your thoughts okay and I think
that might provide a good Anchor Point
for us to talk about some protocols
really a excellent night's sleep
begins in the morning I talked about
this on the previous episode so I won't
go into detail but everyone should get
as much bright light in their eyes
ideally from sunlight first thing in the
morning 10 to 30 minutes outside
depending on how bright it is
eyeglasses or contact lenses are fine
don't wear sunglasses if you can do it
safely if you wake up before the sun
rises turn on bright lights then go
outside once the sun rises if you have
no access to sunlight use a daytime
simulator or similar like a ring light
and get that light in your eyes Okay so
that's all of that in a compact form
caffeine you can inhibit falling asleep
with caffeine you have to figure out
when your threshold is for me I can
drink caffeine up until about three even
four o'clock in the afternoon and sleep
like a baby and still sleep well yes and
Matt Walker our good friend Matt Walker
would say that my sleep isn't as good as
it would be had I cut caffeine out
earlier by like 11 or 12 yeah a.m right
and and I I want to acknowledge you know
Matt is the Michael Jordan of sleep
science and so I'm not gonna you're the
LeBron James yeah well no no and uh in
Fair thank you for the the compliment
but um but no I'm not
um I know a lot of the science and the
protocols but but that's Matt's
wheelhouse and so
um if he says something it's true and if
I say something and and our opinions
conflict it's likely to be something
that the data are still emerging or in
in that case default to Matt being
correct because I yeah just out of uh
due respect for his expertise so
caffeine you know for some people they
can have a two o'clock espresso 2PM
espresso some people it's 4 P.M some
people can drink caffeine at 8 pm and
fall asleep but there I would say
um it's problematic because you're
disrupting the architecture of sleep and
the brain waves associated with sleep
the chemicals and so forth so get that
morning light
cut your caffeine off at the time that
allows you to fall asleep
that Morning Light also sets the timer
on your melatonin Rhythm so you have
this gland in your brain called the
pineal gland that pineal is the source
of melatonin melatonin makes you sleepy
but it does not keep you asleep okay
melatonin starts to rise in the late
evening and continues into the night and
then eventually tapers off this is
naturally occurring melatonin release
not supplemented in melatonin release
the fastest way to slam melatonin into
the pavement and eliminate it in your
system is to look at bright light for I
hate to tell you this even a few seconds
so
you mean at night
anytime at night is typically when
melatonin Rises it's when it's released
in the bloodstream and when it has this
effect of making us sleepy it does a
number of other things you want more
melatonin at night is right right you do
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night or it's eight o'clock and you
decide you want to go to bed at nine or
it's nine o'clock you want to go to bed
at 10 you go into the bathroom and you
flip on the bright lights your melatonin
levels just got crushed down just having
lights on is a the worst thing you can
do yes and it doesn't matter if it's
blue light red light purple light green
light bright lights inhibit melatonin
wow very acutely and therefore you want
to avoid exposure to bright lights at
night if your goal is to be asleep so
the simple rule that governs all this
stuff is when you want to be alert get
bright light in your eyes ideally from
sunlight so that's true in the morning
and throughout the day and when you want
to be sleepy or asleep avoid bright
light in your eyes now many home
environments don't allow you to have
zero lights
and that's not actually necessary you
can just dim the lights in the evening
ideally you also avoid overhead lights
because the neurons in the eye that
trigger this melatonin suppression uh
and so forth they reside in an area of
the eye that views upper visual space so
you could have desk lamps or
um and just dim those down if you're
going to work on a screen dim it way
down will blue blockers help yes but if
the light is bright enough they it's
still going to go you're still going to
inhibit melatonin rule number two
optimize your environment most people
are are primarily visual there's an
interesting study that was published
recently
um just came out and uh that shows that
actually memory and uh recall for
material that's consumed on a phone is
much lower than right on the written
page and there's an interesting
um reason that they they give for this
you know there could be a lot of reasons
I just want to point that out but they
monitored breathing and they monitored
heart rate and they monitored some other
physical logical signals while people
were either reading on a smartphone or
reading paper and what they found was
that breathing was essentially normal or
equivalent in both conditions meaning
people breathed the same way whether or
not they're reading on their smartphone
or reading from a written page but there
was a particular category of of breath
that was abolished by reading on the
smartphone and this is what is referred
to as physiological size talk a lot
about physiological size on the podcast
my lab works on them this is a
spontaneous innate pattern of breathing
that's governed by a little subset of
neurons in in the brain stem for those
who want to know this is a brain stem
area called the parafatial nucleus
discovered by Jack Feldman at UCLA who's
the world expert in the neural
mechanisms of respiration and this low
collection of neurons probably only 100
neurons or so make sure that every three
to five minutes you do what's called a
physiological site which is a very deep
breath sometimes followed by another
short inhale so
and then a long exhale and the double
deep breath with a very deep breath
reinflates the little sacs in the lungs
your lungs aren't just two big bags of
air they actually have hundreds of
millions of little sacks that we call
the avioli of the lungs and when you
don't do these physiological size
so in the second or third minute after
not having done a physiological sigh
these little sacs collapse and they're
kind of moist on the inside so you can
imagine trying to blow open a balloon
that's moist on the inside you need a
little bit of added air pressure and so
the size reinflate those and then on the
exhale allow you to offload carbon
dioxide now this happens even during
sleep every three to five minutes and
I've talked a lot about physiological
size as what I think is really a
terrific real-time tool for reducing
anxiety and calming oneself down indeed
it works very well we have a study
that's out for review now it's a
collaborative work with David Spiegel
and Psychiatry but it but it points out
that these physiological size can be
used double inhale through the nose long
exhale through the mouth to calm down
and it works very well because you
offload carbon dioxide now in this study
about smartphone reading versus reading
on paper what they found is that people
stop engaging in physiological size
during any time they're reading on the
smartphone now it wasn't a perfect study
because they probably also should have a
tablet and a laptop condition so it's
not clear whether or not it's due only
to the reduced aperture of the visual
window that you're narrowing your
attention and there's this sort of app
almost like an apnea a kind of starving
of yourself for oxygen when you do this
but it's very clear I mean it's
abundantly clear that two things one is
nasal breathing and that the other is
getting sufficient oxygen to the brain
is important for comprehension so the
takeaway from this is if ever possible
try and read from a written page and if
you uh or from a book or a piece of
paper and if you can't do that then try
and access whatever you're learning from
as large a screen as you can manage in
that particular environment right and I
do realize when people are commuting you
know and sometimes I'm guilty of looking
at my phone and trying to read papers
and passages on my phone but it's
interesting because this study
highlights the the linkage between this
visual attention or respiration and the
fact that you know our body and our
brain have these innate mechanisms for
making sure that we're getting
sufficient oxygen we're getting
sufficient blood flow to the brain areas
that are required for Learning and so
again I don't want to de-emphasize the
fact that there is a lot of legitimate
clinically diagnosed ADHD out there but
for a lot of people that are struggling
with attention or they feel like they
just can't focus I think we all owe it
to ourselves to ask well what kind of
environment am I creating for myself
that is depriving me of this focus and
what simple things can I do to try and
enhance my ability of focus because I'm
personally of the belief that if
possible and wherever it's not hazardous
to start with behavioral tools right
before ever moving to supplementation or
prescription drugs unless there's a real
dire need I would think that behavioral
tools should be the most valuable for
the simple reason that when you engage
in a behavior over and over again you
get neuroplasticity your brain circuits
change and get better simply taking a
drug or a supplement of any kind
although they can have their value isn't
going to rewire your brain in the ways
that you want you are essentially
dependent on that chemistry in order to
access the state that you want right
rule number three develop alertness the
whole process of neuroplasticity and
learning is really a two-stage process
first there must be focus and alertness
that focus and alertness is associated
with the release of neurochemicals
so-called neuromodulators things like
acetylcholine in particular which sort
of acts as a highlighter pen if you will
for certain Connections in the brain to
to later be reinforced and the
neurochemical adrenaline which is also
called epinephrine also depending on if
you're in the UK or elsewhere a long
interesting story not for this time
about why it has multiple names
epinephrine also called adrenaline is
associated with an increase in kind of
agitation and alertness acetylcholine
think of it as kind of a spotlight or a
highlighter pen for certain Connections
in the brain so you need alertness and
focus and then the second stage is that
it is only during periods of deep rest
in particular sleep and something that I
call non-sleep deep rest which I've
given an acronym because scientists like
acronyms nsdr non-sleep depressed things
like Yoga Nidra things like shallow naps
things like forms of meditation that
don't involve a lot of focused
concentration you're a far more the
experienced meditator than I so I'm
outside my wheelhouse when talking about
meditation but it is only periods of
intense focus and alertness followed by
periods of depressed that allow the
nervous system to change and there is an
abundance of evidence for that so that's
the first thing to understand the brain
actually rewires during deep sleep and
rest because during deep sleep and rest
naps Yoga Nidra deep sleep there's a
replay of the very same cells in the
brain that were active during learning
oftentimes in Reverse for reasons that
are still not understood but at a much
higher repetition rate so you're
actually getting repetitions while you
sleep this is why one will strain to
learn a language or a motor skill or
maths or something like that over and
over and over it doesn't happen you take
a couple nights sleep take a break from
it all of a sudden it's there it's
because it happens in rest now there's
some other things that one can do to
enhance this process further that are
arrive to us from good data first of all
there's a so-called ultradian Rhythm
which is the 90 minute Cycles during
which we can focus pretty well for a
duration of about 90 minutes of course
flickering in and out of focus nobody
really focuses for 90 minutes straight
unless they've built up that capacity or
they are very interested in what they're
learning right they're just wrapped with
attention but usually people flicker in
and out and of course nowadays there's a
lot of literature and ideas about ways
to maintain Focus put the phone away
limit noise some people like background
noise some people like music some don't
it's very contextual highly
individualized
but 90 minutes is sort of the the batch
of time that the brain can focus really
hard on one thing before it needs a true
rest of an hour or two before you can go
back to learning or working very hard
the other thing is that um there are
some very interesting data showing that
shallow naps or nsdr non-sleep depressed
done within four hours of one of these
90-minute learning bouts can be very
beneficial for accelerating learning and
then there are these uh incredible data
on so-called Gap effects so there have
been studies now of of skills that are
physical skills mental skills where
people will for instance try to learn
scales on the piano or a math problem or
a spatial problem or a physical skill
and then at random every so often a
buzzer will go off and the person will
just be told to do nothing sit their
eyes closed or eyes open and do nothing
just stop the learning process for about
10 seconds and then return to doing what
they're doing these are these little
micro rests it turns out that during
those micro rests the hippocampus of
brain areas you know that's associated
with learning and memory and the
neocortex also associated with learning
and memory
undergoes replay of the thing that the
individual is trying to learn at 20
times the speed also in Reverse just as
in sleep and that has can lead and has
been shown to lead to accelerations in
learning so there are these ways I
wouldn't even think of them as hacks
because the word hack is a little tricky
because when I think of the word hack it
seems like doing something with an
object or a tool that wasn't designed
for that purpose right the nervous
system already Harbors these mechanisms
and one can access them through these
little micro rests so whether or not
you're a child or an adult every so
often when trying to learn something
just pause for 10 seconds or so do your
best to just clear your mind of course
it's very hard to clear the mind but
um do your best to clear the mind and
then go back to the learning task as as
it were and that has been shown to very
to significantly accelerate the learning
process and the retention of newly
learned information and then the last
thing you touched on earlier which is
this notion of incremental learning you
said you like to throw yourself into
something as kind of a litmus test of
whether or not you enjoy it or not
turns out that from beautiful work done
by my colleague at Stanford School of
Medicine Eric knitson has shown that yes
it's true that early in development in
humans this would be up until the
mid-20s we can learn things in larger
batches and much more easily than we can
later in life however if one batches
that work into smaller increments
and for so for instance deciding maybe
set a timer turning the phone off
otherwise and saying I'm going to spend
three minutes just three minutes in
trying to intensely learn this thing
even if I feel like I'm failing if one
does that repeatedly those little
increments of learning can lead to an
outsized amount of learning overall and
so the nervous system loves incremental
learning it loves to batch things into
focused little bouts and you know if
that's already the the tools that you've
built up which it sounds like you have
wonderful but if somebody is out there
trying you know struggling to learn
really trying to break things down into
very brief periods of intense Focus that
is the cue by which during sleep the
nervous system will change itself and
this has been shown over and over and
over again even in very late life uh
individuals and people in there you know
we like to think life could go on
further than this but people in their
80s and 90s still have neuroplasticity
there's even evidence that new neurons
can be produced in the hippocampus of
people in their late 80s and 90s so the
capacity is there rule number four use
saunas there are three ways you can do
sauna that I can just toss out as like
brief things if you want to get a really
big growth hormone release for sake of
metabolism fat loss you're training
really really hard in Jiu Jitsu and you
want to recover
you don't want to sauna too often
because the study that um identified
this massive 16-fold increase in growth
hormone they had people do this it's
crazy they got into okay temperatures
are 80 to 100 degrees Centigrade so
that's 176 degrees Fahrenheit to 212
degrees Fahrenheit for 5 to 30 minutes
is the typical ranges that people work
in in these research studies
for maximum growth hormone hormone
release don't do sauna more than once a
week but get into the sauna for 30
minutes
as hot as you can safely tolerate so
probably for you that'll be 210 because
you're I suspect you'll be on the high
end of things
then get out for five to ten minutes
no cold exposure get back in the sauna
for 30 minutes then they had them do it
again out for five minutes back for 30
minutes out for five minutes back for
three minutes they had them do two hours
of sauna exposure to get that growth
hormone release now for the reduction in
likelihood of dying of a cardiovascular
event stroke or otherwise the more often
you do sauna the better so if you look
at all calls all cause mortality or
death due to cardiovascular events and
you look at sauna use frequencies using
the same parameters 80 to 100 degrees
Centigrade
one to seven times per week basically
the more often you get into the sauna
for 30 minutes
across the week so 30 minutes a day is
better than four times a week four times
a week is better than two times a week
and two times a week is better than one
and the reductions in mortality are
really impressive 27 if you get into the
sauna the way I just described not the
two hours a day but 30 minutes
twice a week or three times per week you
reduce the likelihood of dying of a
cardiovascular event by 27 percent
if you do it four or more times per week
you reduce the probability of Dying by
50 percent of a cardiovascular event and
in these studies they rule out other
things that people are doing smoking
they even ask them do you live in an
apartment are you in a happy
relationship like they evaluate other
potentially confounding variables now
for people that don't have access to a
sauna a hot water bath or a hot tub is
going to be your next best bet and if
you don't have access to that do like
the wrestlers do which is you know put
on two sets of uh sweats and a hoodie
and a stocking cap and wrap yourself in
Plastics underneath all that and go for
a run but don't please nobody die of
hypothermia I mean you can die of
warming up too much is this experience
um
Pleasant or stressful in the way so is
it as stressful as a nice bathroom okay
great question people always ask how
cold to make the ice bath or the cold
water or the shower you want it to be
uncomfortably cold meaning you want to
feel like I really want to get out but
you can safely stay in and that's going
to vary by person and experience with
experience yeah with the sauna it's the
same thing
how hot to make it well don't kill
yourself obviously be smart if you're
pregnant you shouldn't be doing this
anyway
um but it's very clear that what you
need is the release of something called
dinorphin we have endorphin which makes
us feel good it binds to these mu opioid
receptors in the body you have dinorphin
which is the terrible feeling that you
get when you're in really hot
temperatures it's also the terrible
effect that alcoholics feel when they
are in withdrawal you feel agitated you
want to get out it's really unpleasant
it's dinorphan binding to the so-called
Kappa opioid receptor is that's what
you're trying to trigger when you do
that a number of things happen you set
off heat shock proteins that go repair
broken proteins and misfolded proteins
it also makes it so that later endorphin
binds its receptor more strongly so when
you have this uncomfortable experience
in the heat
you literally feel better in real life
when pleasurable events come on
when you experience them in the same way
I like to say this that when you get
into a cold ice bath or cold shower the
increase in epinephrine and dopamine is
two to three hundred percent these are
huge increases and they last many hours
this is shown because lately I've got a
little bit pushback on Twitter that
which is you know interesting place
um people say well that's just in mice
no all the studies I just referred to
are all done in humans men and women
fairly broad age ranges so you want to
be uncomfortable in the cold you want to
be uncomfortable in the Heat this is why
I'm not a big fan of infrared saunas
because they only go up to about 160 170
degrees
infrared light and far red light of all
kinds has been shown to be beneficial
for wound healing acne skin eyes there
are even guys now putting on their
testicles because it can increase
testosterone and sperm production yeah
hormone release hormone release but in
terms of the sauna you want that strong
heat stimulus yeah and that's when you
get crawl up to the 200 Mark and so on
whenever I'm in New York and there's
also one in San Francisco although the
one in San Francisco is is clothing
optional just to warn people there's a
place called Archimedes Banya is there
any scientific evidence that being naked
is beneficial in the sauna well in
certain contexts it leads to childbirth
okay but
um I suppose it's not required right for
childbirth but
um but in all seriousness you know in
New York I'll go to a place called Spa
88 and actually uh khabib's picture is
on the wall he goes there and it's a it
there that one it's clothing they
require clothing I always just say that
because it can be a little bit of a
shock to people sometimes if they kind
of walk in their bunch of naked people
that went in San Francisco I if I go I'm
close mostly because you know I run into
co-workers or things like that you know
I I sort of more uh old-fashioned in
that way I suppose but um that you like
to wear clothes they're on co-workers
yes yeah I mean it's just to me it just
seems like you know that just be aware
but but nonetheless the banyas have very
Hots on us because they're russian-owned
and in New York there's one on the Lower
East Side but the spa 88 place they have
some saunas that the moment I get into
those I have a hard time catching a full
breath it burns they've got a cold dunk
that's like a shock and then they've got
a sauna wet sauna steam room that's a
little mellower so the nice thing about
a Banya is you can kind of find your
place and then they do the plaza where
they take the eucalyptus leaves and you
can pay someone and you basically you
cover your groin and then they beat you
with the the the the leaves and it's
supposed to bring the vasculature to the
surface I've only done it once and
frankly I found it um to be a little bit
um unnerving I didn't really like the
experience but I I'll try and get into a
sauna as often as I possibly can which
is you know once or three times per week
and I try and do the cold exposure
shower or immersion but early in the day
because it really wakes you up also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five reward your
progress when you're chasing something
or you're saying you don't have it
you're like needing something you're
saying you don't have it but when you
become comfortable with Where You Are
things start to attract you and you have
energy and you have energy and you're
like a magnet as opposed to an opposite
magnet resisting these things that you
need and want Pursuit is very taxing and
the reason is there's a biochemical
reason for this is it's like wandering
in the desert not knowing if there's
water at all that's really depleting I
mean epinephrine is in the brain and
it's a it's chemical equivalent in the
body is adrenaline those are the same
thing and if you're constantly in
Pursuit right you're just pursuing
external goals external goals external
goals it will wear your nervous system
down you will be exhausted and you will
one will eventually run aground you'll
become mentally depressed the key is to
figure out what are the rewards that you
can acquire along the way internally
remember it's subjective there can also
be external rewards because many things
have Milestones you know a series A or a
series B for a company then the IPO or
later reaching a million users are doing
this yeah that we have engagements
before we have weddings typically right
yeah
um there are those rare instances where
just go and get married but typically
there's a lot of build up that is
designed you know that fortunately it
you know provides these uh reward
mechanisms so the key thing is that
you can't just be all gas pedal all the
time without rewarding yourself however
the reward that dopamine is so powerful
because it actually as I mentioned
before it actually is the chemical
substrate for epinephrine it creates a
reservoir of more energy and again I'm
not talking about caloric energy or
glycogen mind energy it's it's mental
energy it's the it's the desire to push
on it's a desire to keep going so we
need some consistent dopamine hits
throughout the days or months to give us
more energy to pursue that's right but
we don't want to be over pursued because
then we'll burn out that's right and so
everyone has to find where that sweet
spot is that kind of you know on the
freeway driving where it's really smooth
and seamless where you're not on the
accelerator the whole time where you're
in a gear that's appropriate and you
know we're talking now in terms of sort
of
um you know Neuroscience lens on these
things but the key is always going to be
practices it's going to be just as early
we're talking about bringing stress
levels up or down depending on you know
alertness levels up or down depending on
the kind of stress you're experiencing
the reward system is great because when
you let's say you're a person that can
very easily access this dopamine reward
so you're always excited you know people
say hey let's do this and your your
mantras let's go and you just kind of go
well we call it science very low
activation energy you just go
that's great those people do run the
risk of burnout although there are these
people that we occasionally encounter
that just seem to have Boundless Energy
for everything and they tend to get a
lot more done because they have a lot
more internal reward and you'll notice
they're getting rewards from all the
little things and it's 100 subjective
it's like hearing funny jokes all day
long you can just keep going and it's
only the beginning of relationships when
people fall in love you know it's a real
thing but it is associated with with a
big flood of dopamine in the system
makes everything seem exciting and
possible and new and I think that we
also know other people that they have a
very hard time accessing this dopamine
system and they either place it under
the complete control of external things
so they're miserable until they get the
payoff
and then sometimes they're even
miserable yeah or they really just don't
they haven't learned the skills of how
to access it so how do we trick our mind
to find rewards in subjective things
that aren't actually physically coming
to us okay so um I'll tell a brief
anecdote about an experiment that's
really important this was done many
years ago in a psychology department
I think it was done at Bing Nursery
School at Stanford but I could be wrong
about that so um I don't want to uh
state that as absolute fact but the
experiment nonetheless was done where
they looked at kids in schools these are
kids about Nursery School age or maybe a
little bit older and they looked at what
they did during recess and they they
found that some kids really like to draw
and so these kids would naturally just
Orient towards the crayons and pens and
draw and then
for a short while they rewarded the kids
for drawing those same kids they would
give them a gold star or a little
sticker or something that was special
and made them feel special so they were
giving them an external reward then they
removed the reward and what they found
is those kids drew at a much lower
frequency they somehow lost the
intrinsic pleasure of drawing huh
because they were used to getting an
extrinsic suddenly they Associated the
drawing they thought they they weren't
conscious but they their nervous system
said oh I guess I was doing it for the
reward now there's less reward and
without going into a lot of details
there's a very solid scientific
phenomenon called reward prediction
error which says that if you get less
dopamine at the end than you anticipated
it's a letdown if you get more at the
end then it feels great now what this
all translates to is once again learning
how to attach internal rewards to the
process of whatever it is that you want
to do in order to get you to the thing
you really want and so the the short
answer is actually I was asked this um
recently someone said okay how can I
ensure that once I succeed this was
somebody who was doing very well in
their pursuit of a goal and they were
getting close and they said how can I be
sure that when I get to the win that I
don't lose the ability to keep working
because I really want this pain I'm not
satisfied right and I said well there's
two ways one is make sure that that
reward really bask in it really
appreciate what you've done and what's
come to you and but and here's a very
important but is but take that feeling
of being saturated with dopamine the
huge win and attach it to the effort
process that got you there rule number
six get sunlight the most dominant
zeitge Gaber as we say timekeeper that
governs all these States including sleep
is light there's no question about it
and you ask any circadian biologist to
say there's a kind of a principle of
circadian biology which is that light is
the dominant zeitge Gaber called
zeitgeber because the people who Define
this were German and I'm pronouncing it
incorrectly because I don't speak German
it's clear that if possible one should
view sunlight or at least get outside
even if it's cloudy outside within the
first hour of waking
and if you wake up before the sun comes
out to flip on as many artificial lights
as possible if your goal is to be awake
if your goal is to go back to sleep
definitely keep the lights dim but
getting sunlight in your eyes even
through cloud cover is going to set in
motion a number of different biological
events read out first through certain
cells in the eyes these so-called
melanopsin intrinsically photosensitive
ganglion cells is the fancy name they
were discovered by David Burson at Brown
University and they send a signal to
your hypothalamus which then sets in
motion a huge number of hormonal and
neural events in the body they create a
cortisol pulse that wakes you up further
sets the Baseline for your attention
throughout the day
also sets a timer of about 16 hours not
coincidentally on your first melatonin
pulse which will happen in the evening
so it's timing when your sleep is going
to come people who stay indoors in dark
environments for the early part of the
day just looking at their phone you're
not getting enough light stimulation
the tricky thing is that later in the
evening
about 17 hours after you've been awake
or when you woke up what you'll find is
that even a minimum of light from
screens can shift your circadian clock
and the reason is that there's a gradual
shift in the sensitivity of the retina
to external light so you need a lot of
light ideally sunlight early in the day
and of course you don't want to stare
directly at any light that's so bright
that it's painful you don't have to look
directly into the sun absolutely blink
you can be kind of off center from the
Sun but try and get out there without
sunglasses if you can people always ask
uh can I wear eyeglasses or contacts I
say absolutely because that actually
will focus the light to your retina
that's what they're designed to do
through a window or a windshield simply
will not work as well because of the
filtration of the wavelengths of light
that you want and then there's a lot of
data to support the fact that getting as
much bright light in your eyes
throughout the day provided it's not
painfully bright is excellent for your
wakefulness mechanisms and even for the
mechanisms of the brain and body that
control metabolism and feeding mood and
well-being this is the work mainly of
Samurai at the National Institutes of
mental health he's the uh the head of
the chronobiology unit at the National
Institutes of mental health so Samara
would say get as much bright light in
your eyes as you can early in the day
and throughout the day and then
somewhere close to bedtime trough that
and live in the darkest environment you
possibly can manage safely he's not a
big fan of being in completely
light absent environments but that
simple behavior of early light viewing
most days if not all days sets in motion
these three phases that lend themselves
best to focused work creative work the
ability to stay awake most of the day
naps are fine we know provided they
don't interfere with nighttime sleep so
naps should be shorter than 90 minutes
but if any of a nap of any duration
prevents you from falling and staying
asleep at night then you don't want to
nap so light is the dominant way that
you set this this whole process in
motion and we know based on work that I
wasn't involved in but that David
Spiegel did with the great Robert
sapolsky that if these cortisol pulse
doesn't arrive early enough in the day
and it start because starts arriving in
the afternoon that's a physiological
signature of depression and anxiety so
that cortisol pulse is happening one way
or another and you want to Anchor to the
early part of the day and so if you're
feeling Wide Awake anxious in the sort
of wired and tired late in the day
chances are you're not getting enough
sunlight early in the day and throughout
the day rule number seven try the on
sleep deep rest non-sleep deep rest nsdr
is an acronym that I coined because it
encompasses a lot of practices that are
not meditation per se
but that bring the brain and body into a
state of relaxation and focus so
hypnosis is one variant of nsdr there
are other variants of nsdr you can just
look these up and you'll find them and I
think that they've caught on and that
the Google the CEO of Google uh is an
avid practitioner of nsdr
because it has this amazing ability to
reset your energy levels and focus
whereas with meditation many people find
meditation hard and part of the reason
they find it hard is that it requires
focus nsdr is a state which is very calm
and relaxing you don't have to work too
hard you're just listening to a script
whereas most forms of meditation not all
but most forms of meditation involve
cranking up the activity in your
prefrontal cortex and trying to see your
thoughts as opposed to thinking your
thoughts or
um focus on your breath but then third
personing yourself in some respect and
that's work and so many people who
meditate quite intensely feel more
exhausted now that doesn't mean that
meditation doesn't have any utility but
it's distinctly different than nsdr and
I think that people are working
certainly the CEO of Google after
imagine is working very hard and using
his forebrain if he's going to have 20
or 30 minutes to take a break he should
and I think this is what he's doing he
should go out for a jog and not listen
to anything and just kind of let his
mind wander or sit there and a chair and
just zone out or do nsdr the problem is
people are not that good at shifting
States we are all actually pretty good
at even people with severe ADHD made an
episode about this can become hyper
focused on things that they actually
enjoy
because dope and most of the drugs
designed to treat ADHD are drugs that
increase the levels of dopamine so when
you like something there's dopamine
release and you can focus it's when you
don't like something that's hard to
focus shifting States is hard I'm sure
you've experienced this if you've ever
been in deep research or podcasting
podcasting and then all of a sudden you
go for a run you'll probably spend the
first third of that run thinking and
then in the middle third you're kind of
that thinking is is fractured a bit and
then in the final third is where you
finally get to relax because the brain
doesn't shift States very quickly we can
go from sleep to wakefulness quickly we
can go from wakefulness to sleep quickly
but we don't shift between different
states of Consciousness like a step
function
except in rare cases right fear is one
all of a sudden we hear an explosion
right now it's a step function we're in
fear or we're in alertness right
um heightened state of alertness but
nsdr is terrific at allowing people to
learn to shift their state and I
actually would venture to argue that
part of the value of meditation and
exercise is the actual state that you
get into in deep meditation or exercise
but just as valuable is the transition
that you have to take yourself through
from one state of mind to the other and
then back again I when I look you know
David Goggins he always seems to come up
but he does he represents so many
important things Drive determination
override of emotional state
going from being a 300 pound plus person
to a fit person through he's never
revealed anything
substantial about what he ate or what he
didn't need he basically says like
listen run a lot eat less right
um
but what's remarkable is
so much of what he says is about those
transitions about taking oneself from a
state of I don't want to to scruffing
oneself like you're going to do it
anyway and then being able to carry that
into into regular life so to speak so I
think that um nsdr is immensely powerful
it's zero cost and one of the reasons
I'm such a fan of people doing it is
that most people don't stick to a
meditation practice
there are also been a few cases you
might find this interesting there's a
book by Scott Carney I forget what it's
called I think it's called the
Transcendence trap or something I'm
gonna have that title wrong but
there have been a fair number of cases
of people that go and do very extensive
meditation silent meditation Retreats
who then return to normal life and end
up killing themselves
there are states of mind inside of
extended meditations or silent
meditations that are very beneficial and
I'm certainly not suggesting people
don't meditate but I know at least one
person who came back from one of these
long extended meditation Retreats and
wasn't able to shift their state back
into one that was functional in regular
life and that book includes a very
dramatic story I don't want to give it
away in case people
um check out the book but Scott told the
story to me directly once where
so someone feels they've reached
enlightenment
and then commit suicide so these very
unusual brain states are are potentially
hazardous if people can't return from
them rule number eight meditate how do
we start opening up and being more
comfortable in the discomfort of change
not just growth but just change in
shifts that we don't expect and predict
yeah I think two ways um one I'll just
go back to this fundamental feature of
the nervous system which is it's trying
to make predictions so the reason why
change is stressful even positive change
believe it or not is quote unquote
stressful I agree uh is because of this
and the release of adrenaline and and
Associated molecules with any time
things change I mean if you look at the
psychologists have worked this out
there's a hierarchy of stressors
um and of course at the at the top of
that hierarchy are awful things that we
don't you know I think at the top to be
honest I think death of a child is is
perhaps the the greatest stressor
divorce death of a loved one
um these kinds of horrible things that
we wouldn't wish on anyone then as one
goes down not too far below you see
things like moving to a new home or
apartment yeah you think well that could
be a great event right birth of a new
child and you think wait a second I
thought that's supposed to be one of the
greatest choice in life and indeed it is
but it's stressful to the nervous system
because so many things have to be
reconfigured not to say anything about
the lack of sleep with a newborn and
this kind of thing so
change is always going to force our
brain to make more assessments of our
environment one of the things that we
can say about the brain for sure is that
once it learns something it likes to not
have to think about it when you walk
because you already know how to walk you
don't think right left right left right
left but when you learn how to dance a
new step or something of that sort or a
new skill uh sport skill you have to
think about it and it's work and anytime
we have to think about behaviors and
they aren't simply reflexive that work
as we call it isn't It's a combination
of the release of things like adrenaline
epinephrine in the brain and body I
should say from the adrenals in the body
but also in the brain from a little
brain area called Locus ceruleus that is
X is kind of a sprinkler system for the
brain to kind of wake up all brain areas
saying okay let's pay attention to a lot
of stuff here very basic system
um but but very fundamental system it's
literally a wake-up system for the brain
works in parallel with the release of
adrenaline into our body
now one way to deal with change is to
Simply know this right to understand
that if one feels stressed or agitated
around a new move or you have a partner
who's really stressed about a new move
even though it's exciting it should be
exciting that that's perfectly normal
because what they're experiencing is
this increase in agitation and alertness
and it also makes it harder to enter
deeply relaxed States because the brain
is in a mode of predictions making
predictions what's happening next
thinking thinking thinking and one of
the things that's key to falling asleep
each night and replenishing our ability
to think and make predictions is the
ability to turn off thinking this is why
I'm such a fan of what traditionally was
called yoga nidro which literally means
yoga sleep lying down it's a form of
meditation as you know and with
breathing Etc
um I I certainly I want to point out
that I have no desire to rename any of
these ancient practices these are
beautiful practices they've been built
up over thousands of years the reason I
call sometimes batch yoga nijer with
so-called nsdr non sleep deep rest is
that unfortunately both in science and
in traditional cultures around some of
these behaviors the language has become
a barrier for people to try them I agree
I'm not trying to wash away any of the
the wonderful culture and tradition
around these I want to be very clear
about that but ultimately it's about
accessing a state of mind as for anyone
that's listened to a Yoga Nidra script
and I should say I do Nitra every day I
have for almost a decade now it's
without question along with viewing
Morning Light sunlight the most powerful
practice I think I can recommend to
anyone
um it is about as you always hear in a
classic nature script you move away from
thinking and doing to being and feeling
now what is that if we take a
neuroscience lensity what is this
thinking and doing being and feeling
it's about shutting down of the
prefrontal cortex which is making
predictions what's happening next right
as we move into sleep you enter that
kind of liminal state where things
become disjointed right a cat flies
through the room and then you might jerk
yourself awake and it's kind of odd but
that's the state of not thinking and
doing and just being and feeling being
in one's pure somatic experience so I
would say
in order to move through change
designate 20 to 30 minutes each day to
put the brain into a state of
non-thinking non-doing and into a state
of quote unquote being and feeling so
not making predictions now the tricky
thing is when one is stressed that's
especially hard to do yeah and this is
why I think what is it tiknahan said you
know what is that who said you know
um when stress you know I meditate every
day but when stress meditate twice as
long something like that when I don't
think I have time like that is
it's a skill and so this ability to turn
off thinking enhances one's ability to
enter sleep which is vital for mental
and physical health obviously learning
etc for reasons we discussed so develop
the ability to deliberately disengage
from thinking and doing and do that
during periods of low stress right 20 to
30 minutes a day even 10 minutes a day
of just learning teaching oneself and
practicing the art of turning off
prediction is an incredibly valuable
skill and then the other one is to just
understand that we're being bombarded
with contextual change all the time you
know I love Instagram I teach science on
Instagram I see you there daily yeah um
and so scrolling on Instagram is an
interesting experience because in five
minutes you can look at a thousand
different contexts
the human brain has never dealt with
that kind of change before even when
television when I was growing up there
were three or four good channels then it
went to cable and then now you get onto
an airplane or something you got 240
channels yeah that's that's a drop in
the bucket compared to what we can get
in in a social media feed yeah so I
think we just need to be aware that the
brain can work with that but then what
you're turning on is an ability to walk
into a new context and and figure it out
the statistics imagine if if an
Instagram feed and I'm not demonizing
Instagram I think they're wonderful I
think they provide a wonderful resource
truly but imagine if we walked out of
this room and it was a completely
different landscape it was a jungle then
we turned the corner and go into what I
would think was the kitchen and it was
the kitchen of the some you know of what
some Thomas Keller uh restaurant in New
York turn the corner and all of a sudden
we're under water that's social media
yeah and we can cope with that so so if
I think about it that way then I think
if we can cope with that then we can
cope with transitions in so-called real
life with with ease now some people have
more situational awareness than others
they walk into an environment and
they're sensing all the things other
people walk into an environment and
they're very good at narrowing their
attentional Spotlight the latter group
actually has a bit of an advantage they
probably wouldn't be so good as a
special operator in the military that
has to develop situational advantage or
a police officer or a teacher but
they're going to be immensely good at
one-on-one interactions because they can
make the room disappear and so but we
need both kinds of people and we all
need to learn how to sort of brighten
and broaden these attentional spotlights
and narrow them as well and I'll just
briefly say we are Old World primates as
it turns out and we have the capacity to
do what's called covert attention yeah I
can pay attention to you but I can also
notice that in my periphery there's
something else going on so I've got two
spotlights now but I am dividing my
attention we can't do three
simultaneously but what I can also do is
decide to merge those two spotlights and
intensify them and now narrow the
aperture of my visual window and my
auditory window so we should always
think of ours that our attention is two
spotlights that can be very broad or it
can be very narrowly focused and that we
can overlap them yeah and I think that's
fantastic I think we should all know how
to do both yeah we should learn how to
narrow the aperture of our Focus deeply
engage but also deliberately disengage
and the process of falling asleep that
we were talking about before is the
practice of learning how to take that
attentional Spotlight move those two
apart and then not dim them but extend
that same Luminosity out more broadly
more broadly and then we're off to sleep
yeah so so it's about deliberate control
of the nervous system and unfortunately
we all know how to focus on something if
we're very stressed or excited by it
most people don't learn how to turn off
this focus and learn how to deliberately
disengage and one of my Great Hopes for
Humanity is that children and adults
will learn how to deliberately disengage
yeah because it benefits sleep which
benefits mental and physical health and
also if you think about it most of the
bad things that we do to ourselves and
others and that people do to one another
most not all but most are from a
heightened state of reactivity yeah
where we're just not conscious yes and
that's because our aperture our window
of attention is too narrow we're not
taking in to account the full space and
time of what we're thinking about yeah
and as a last Point space and time are
linked in the brain uh if you have a
narrow visual Focus you tend to have a
narrow time slicing right which makes
sense if you think about like a little
kid watching ants on the ground and then
gets called into dinner and all of a
sudden the way you batch time is
different when you're sleepy you tend to
batch things in Big Blocks okay or when
you're bored big blocks of time when
you're very excited stressed or happily
excited you're in that fast frame rate
you've gone from 60 frames per second
which I think is a typical smartphone to
a thousand frames per second wow so
you're catching all the micro nuances
but you're missing everything else rule
number nine release trauma if ever there
was a phenomenon in life that I'm struck
by is uh it's trauma and
um you know it's it's incredible to me
how
you know we experience these things uh
to some for some people more than others
right um
you know to some extent everyone has
trauma to some extent I think we need to
be fair and say that some people have a
tremendous amount of trauma in other
people less
um but that there's some consistent
themes that the psychoanalyst actually
had right which is that for many people
there's this what the analysts would
call a repetition compulsion right
somebody experiences something really
terrible as a child and then as an adult
they find themselves seeking out similar
types of situations and it's just the
most illogical thing one can imagine and
the analysts would say well this is a
reparative wish an attempt to throw
oneself back subconsciously throw
oneself back into these scenarios to get
a different outcome right so for example
if you had a deadbeat dad you're gonna
you're a young woman you're gonna search
out you're gonna seek out like a
boyfriend who has those same behavior
patterns
logic yeah in one case it's the exact
opposite in which case we might say well
that's a more functional step in the
other case it's um yes this repetition
compulsion making the same mistakes
despite knowing better right and not
necessarily from this standpoint of
addiction where there are some deeper
dopamine circuits driving that
um so you know trauma is fascinating in
that way I mean what do we know about
trauma and again I'm borrowing from some
of my conversations with David Spiegel
and with Anna Lemke who I know you've
had on the podcast
you know it's very clear that relief
from trauma in some way or another
almost always involves going
deliberately bringing oneself back into
the state of mind and body that occurred
during the trauma as horrible as that
might seem avoiding that seems to be an
issue and then gradually or hopefully
quickly but in some cases gradually
desensitizing oneself to that experience
as not just a overwhelming horrible
experience but a sad but no longer
overwhelming experience so that they can
gain some sort of
um ability to think inside of the the
memory and to parse uh parse what
happened one resounding theme that I've
collected in talking to trauma
therapists and exploring a lot of the
therapies for trauma
is that you know oftentimes trauma
involves a deep confusion for whatever
reason a deep confusion about who was
responsible and this is something that's
somewhat complicated and um can be
troubling to think about but people will
experience a a trauma a car crash a
sexual assault a um devastating
Financial loss can also be a trauma and
then somehow in that in one's mind
it's not clear whether or not that was
something that happened to them or that
they created for themselves now the
typical script of this was people
talking about oh you know I shouldn't
have been out that late or dressed that
way or acted that way but it's actually
can be much more subtle and diabolical
than that it can be that uh it can start
to Route into people's own perceptive
self like maybe I'm not worthy of being
happy and therefore the fact that this
happened makes total sense people create
these these crazy scripts and crazy
because they don't match any real world
facts but they do match a lot of
internal structure and so it becomes
very complex to unpack all this but what
we know for sure is that accessing the
state of mind and body that resembles
the state of mind and body during the
trauma is the first step in moving
trauma out of the body so-called trauma
release now almost always that has to be
done in concert with a really
well-trained uh physician or clinician
because that can be overwhelming
certainly the first time there's also
some evidence based on some decent
studies that show that
accessing deliberately accessing states
of high on autonomic arousal that are
independent from the trauma so things
like ice baths things like Hard Exercise
things like very very intense
experiences separate from the traumatic
memory can be useful in allowing people
to attain Comfort at high levels of
autonomic arousal right I mean you're
trying to essentially say you know go
back to this place and work it through
try and get some space or some distance
from the emotion and yet for some people
just an elevation in heart rate is
overwhelming for them and so they're not
even going to set foot on the first step
up the mountain when in fact that's
exactly what they need to do so there's
now a kind of movement in Psychiatry and
psychology to bring in more of these I
guess you could call them somatic
approaches but to my mind they're really
physiological approaches they're really
approaches that teach people how to be
tolerant of high levels of autonomic
arousal and so that's that's something
that we're starting to see a shift in
the other thing I should just
acknowledge is that you know until the
psychoanalysts the cognitive behavioral
therapists the neuroscientists and the
psychiatrists join arms we are going to
go around and around and around this
Merry-Go-Round of not knowing how to
deal with trauma and feelings right I
mean we're all told to feel our feelings
but not trust them as facts and yet here
I'm telling you that most successful
trauma therapies involve getting right
up close to that event really letting it
almost overtake oneself and then start
to create these these gaps and these
gaps that I'm referring to are real gaps
in neural circuitry that that worked
from Spiegel and many others have shown
and the work doing brain imaging under
conditions of ketamine and other types
of pharmacologic therapies have shown
that there there are active associations
normally between the prefrontal cortex
which is thinking planning and reasoning
the insula which is an area of the brain
that monitors how we feel internally and
then some of these areas like the
anterior cingulate cortex which are
involved in kind of self-monitoring and
figuring out how much of what I'm
experiencing is coming from thoughts and
things within and from things in my
environment and under conditions of
extreme autonomic arousal and somewhat
counterintuitively under conditions of
deep relaxation those neural circuits
are able to rearrange themselves and
when one emerges from those treatments
the default Network then is one of
perspective it's one of saying ah this
is something that happened but it was
not my fault or this is something that
happened and indeed it set me up for a
number of positive opportunities in my
life all the sorts of stories that we
hear about all the time so if this is
sounding a little bit abstract I'm
trying my best to put some structure on
it but where there's a lack of structure
I'll
um you know kind of wriggle out of that
by saying that you know there is no
clear answer as to where trauma is
represented in the nervous system many
people talk about trauma being manifest
as physical symptoms in their body and
that used to be considered kind of you
know pseudoscience makes perfect sense
makes perfect sense after all the
nervous system is the brain the eyes and
the spinal cord for central nervous
system and then every organ in your body
is innervated by
nerve cells neurons and peripheral
nervous system so the manifestation of
things in the body and in the brain is
shouldn't surprise anybody and I think
one of the Great
expansions of Neuroscience in the last
few years is that whereas five ten years
ago you would find very few grants and
laboratory you know grants funding work
in Laboratories and Laboratories working
on elements of the nervous system in the
body very very few maybe 98 of the focus
was on things within the brain memory
Consciousness Vision hearing Etc now an
enormous number of Laboratories are
moving into this mind-body relationship
but they don't call it that they call it
the peripheral nervous system the
autonomic nervous system right they call
them gut brain axis right so we have
fancy names to
um to disguise the fact that we're
studying mind and body and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is learn to modulate focus
we have to distinguish between
modulators and mediators and I'll do
this very briefly there are a lot of
things that will modulate your state of
focus but they don't directly mediate
your sense of focus so for instance if
right now a fire alarm went off in this
building it would modulate our attention
we would get up and leave it would be
very hard to do what we're doing with
that banging in the background at least
at first
so it's modulating Focus but it's not
really
involved in the mechanisms of Focus
right
in the same way being well rested when
you sleep your autonomic nervous system
that adjusts states of alertness and
focus and calm works better than when
you're sleep deprived so if you're
sleeping better you're going to focus
better so I always answer this way to a
question like this because the best
thing that anyone can do for their
mental health physical health and
performance in athletic or cognitive
Endeavors or creative Endeavors is to
make sure that you're getting enough
quality sleep
enough of the time for you and that's
going to differ we could talk about what
that means now in terms of things that
mediate Focus
without getting into the description of
mechanisms because we have podcasts
about that
it's very clear that mental focus
follows visual Focus provided that
you're a sighted person
much of the training that's being done
now in China to teach kids to focus
better literally has them stare at a
Target blinking every so often but
really training themselves to breathe
calmly and maintain a tight visual
aperture
when you read you have to maintain a
tight visual aperture you're literally
scrolling like a highlighter in your
mind's eye right it's kind of obvious
once you hear it so for people that have
problems focusing sleep well
learn to dilate and contract your visual
field consciously this can be done if
you practice it a little bit and then be
as I said before it is very hard to get
into a state of focus like a step
function immediately like snapping your
fingers what you can do is you can pick
any object but ideally an object at
roughly the same distance
placed at roughly the same distance to
which you're going to do that work and
stare at it you're allowed to Blink and
as your mind starts to drift every once
in a while to understand that's normal
but try and narrow your visual aperture
and bring that into your visual field so
that that's the most prominent thing
kind of like portrait mode in your phone
this would look very different in
portrait mode than it would in just a
standard photograph mode and then after
doing that for 30 to 60 seconds moving
into the work that you're about to do
and really Encourage Yourself to do that
if you're somebody who's low vision or
no vision you're going to use your ears
to do this Braille readers have trouble
focusing sometimes because they feel
other stuff and they hear other stuff so
you learn to adjust that aperture
consciously and then of course the
pharmacologic tools just enough caffeine
but not too much right we've talked
about white noise Brown Noise music or
no music really varies but it's very
clear that binaural beats of 40 hertz
can shift the brain into a heightened
state of focus and cognition so if
you're going to use binaural beats which
should definitely be used with
headphones
and there are a number of free apps out
there and sources uh 40 Hertz seems to
be the frequency that best supports the
brain shifting into a particular can you
give us the some some some binaural
beats yeah so you're going to look for
you'd want to find a uh an app that
offers 40 Hertz I think brainwave allows
you to
um slide bar up to the particular
frequency that you want and I should say
that um there are other frequencies that
are interesting but 40 Hertz binaural
beat seems to be the one that there's
the most quality research so it's a it's
like a b yeah oh yeah but you're saying
there's a lot of mixed science on the on
the yeah white noise you really should
be doing this with headphones because
binaural beats are best accomplished by
feeding two different frequencies to the
two ears and then you have What's called
the this brain stem area that reads out
what are called interoral time
differences and then it extracts the the
the Delta essentially turn it up
and then in other things it can enhance
Focus so you know the pharmacology
around this is pretty interesting things
that tickle the dopamine pathway in the
acetylcholine pathway they work yeah
um there's your riddle in your Adderalls
your modafinils which are prescription
and there's a lot of non-prescription
use of those prescription drugs not so
much in my generation but in people 35
and younger you know I hear all the time
from day Traders and programmers and
stuff and kids that play video games a
lot of riddle and Adderall use
I think that unless it's prescribed by a
doctor for a specific purposes of ADHD I
don't think people should go that route
frankly hits the dopamine system way too
hard also has a number of negative
effects on the sexual side effects all
sorts of things that you just wouldn't
want there are a few compounds like
Alpha GPC
um 300 milligrams to 600 milligrams of
alpha GPC with a cup of espresso if
you're well rested you're like a laser
for 90 minutes maybe two hours but then
it's going to taper off and you have to
just recognize that and then there's
this whole world of nootropics now and
people trying to figure out the racetams
paracetams and phenyl ethylamine
combined with this and you know it's not
quite in the place where you'd like it
to be there are a few companies that are
doing this better than others we talk
about some of these on the podcast but
um I would always start with behavioral
tools and then consider pharmacology and
and then I suppose the the other thing
for focus is um they're these you this
is a little more esoteric but we covered
this in an episode on workplace
optimization
um where you place your screen is
important staring down at a screen is
not going to be as effective as placing
it at eye level or above you when the
eyes are up literally your eyes are
directed forward or up the brain stem
centers for alertness are activated when
your eyes are down it's actually you're
you're sort of it's like being pulled
underwater a little bit in the autonomic
arousal sense it's you're closing your
eyes I mean um is one it reflects the
brainstem centers that are active
becoming less or for for alert and
excuse me becoming less active but
there's a really cool effect that's
active in this room right now which is
that there's been some really
interesting studies that when people
work in small compact spaces or wear a
hoodie or a hat that can also improve
focus like blinders on a horse for
obvious reasons now based on what I said
before but also
analytic work or the kind of work where
there's a correct answer that you're
seeking is best supported by these kind
of low ceiling environments whereas
there's something called the cathedral
effect which is when you work in an
outdoor environment or a high ceiling
environment it lends itself to kind of
pun intended kind of loftier ideas and
more creativity and that probably has to
do with the fact that there's a natural
tendency a reflex to expand your visual
field in these high ceiling environments
expansion of the visual field
changes the way the brain works in the
time domain your engineering and biology
oriented listeners will understand this
for the and music for those that don't
the best way to think about it is when
you have a narrow Focus portrait mode on
your phone or you're very alert you are
fine slicing life in time it's like a um
think of it as a high frame rate like
you're shooting in slow motion when you
have a uh when you dilate your your view
you're taking bigger time bins and the
one way to just let this hopefully land
home is that if you've ever had a really
exciting day or podcast interview or
experience of any kind your system is
flooded with dopamine and norepinephrine
alertness and motivation all this
excitement it seems like it goes by very
very fast and yet when you think back to
that it seems like a lot happened this
happened and that happened now think
about waiting in the doctor's office in
a blank waiting room with no interesting
art on the walls it feels like it goes
by very very very slow dopamine and
norepinephrine are all time low and yet
when you think back on that experience
it's as if nothing happened because you
were you were parsing time differently
so those are the roughly the tools and
the and the neurochemicals around time
perception in the time domain uh there's
a wonderful book I'm forgetting the
title so wonderful I forget the title by
Dean um bodomano from UCLA but I think
it's called the brain is a time machine
that talks about this expansion and
contraction of the time domain and what
you can do is to leverage it for work
and creativity focus and so on
there's an interesting process that that
occurs when people start to realize that
rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control this idea of duration
path and outcome and attach an internal
sense of reward just that you're doing
well to reward yourself mentally just
say I'm doing well I'm actually on the
right path
to do that inside of the
demands that come from the external
world the more often that we can
self-reward some aspect of the process
provided it's in the right direction of
what we're trying to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more Focus we're going to have
for that and remember the nor the reason
I say energy I don't throw that around
Loosely is that limiting amount of
noradrenaline is constantly being kept
at Bay you're literally buffering the
quit response and so when people start
realizing that if they set the goals
inside of the larger goal and
self-reward each one of those they
essentially have an infinite amount of
energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most uh in the Special Operations
community and people that are selected
essentially for this process it's one of
the things that's been intriguing to me
I have some friends from the SEAL Teams
and I don't begin to you know really
understand the real work that they do
deployed because I've never done that
kind of work but I've always been
intrigued by the selection process the
so-called buds process right because
carrying logs and getting in cold water
and all that that's not really how the
work is that's really not what the work
is about so the selection process is
interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit I mean I think like
there might be a couple people that just
show up to show up but everybody is
absolutely convinced and then a very
small subset of them make it through and
I'd be willing to bet that the ones that
make it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's a reward process
maybe it's through self-punishment maybe
it's through self-reward
um in the positive sense but they're
able to control something inside an
environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors and
I've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to not in order to get
through you just have to not quit
remember people aren't being deselected
they're not saying get out of here
you're not good enough you're not people
are deciding that for themselves and so
it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and I believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters and the
people when I say manage I think that
the people they get through knowing some
of these people quite well had an
internal process by which they could
reward themselves for doing something
that might have just looked trivial to
everybody else but it gave them more gas
more energy right right and what's
interesting is the process the kind of
unconscious Genius of of the buds
process is that they've picked two
sensory events that are
across the board challenging for
everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you right it's not like heat
which can kill you it's cold water and
sleep deprivation and so the ability to
do these like what I'm calling dpos this
uh duration path and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know uh you know when
you have a when you have well-fed well
slept you can do anything you can be in
any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is these deep reserves of
the nervous system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us pay more
attention to how we feel than the
demands of the world around us remember
that yeah basic challenge in the nervous
system and so sleep deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because it's
very easy again rested to do all this
but so what they do is they're sleep
deprived people they put them in cold
water they're trying to get them more in
touch with the way that they feel inside
than what they need to do in response to
the external demands right everyone I
know that's made it through that process
did it slightly differently but I'll
tell you how they didn't do it they
didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by micro slicing the day or slicing the
day into a series of meals that they
just needed to get to and then rewarding
themselves for getting to that next
Milestone so they don't know I mean most
of them you know probably had very low
concept of dopamine and norepinephrine
but that's the process that's also the
process I think that allows someone to
finish an ultra I've never run an ultra
but I think that process of self-reward
is grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and I
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and I think it's therefore I think
it's it's so key because I think people
think that uh it's just so key that
people understand excuse me that these
circuits are not unique to people who
run Ultras or people that make it
through uh you know stringent filter
Special Operations Command yeah it's the
same thing that it is interesting yeah
dopamine is not just about reward it's
one of the biggest misconceptions
dopamine is about motivation and drive
it's like a jet that propels you along a
path how do we get more dopamine you
practice subjectively releasing dopamine
in your mind like wow okay so that's a
great question first of all there are
ways you can get more dopamine release
through thoughts or through drugs or
through supplements I want to be really
clear there is a drug there are two
drugs actually that will cause massive
release of dopamine they're called
cocaine and methamphetamine the problem
gets us addicted because it feels so
good the problem is exactly the problem
is cocaine and methamphetamine stimulate
so much dopamine release that the drug
becomes the only Source it becomes the
goal of your path it becomes the path
and the destination and you look at
people's lives when they do a lot of
cocaine and methamphetamine and that
Baseline on their life goes down
dopamine is this incredibly powerful
molecule that allows us to buffer the
effort process it allows us to be an
effort longer and it allows us to
actually eventually enjoy the process of
effort and not think about the reward
but just say oh I'm enjoying the process
right well you just described the first
step the first step in learning to
attach dopamine to the effort process
which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to be
very careful about how much you focus on
the end goal keeping the goal in mind is
important for like a proper orientation
you have to know the ultimate
destination but if at any point we were
to evaluate our progress relative to
that end goal or if we don't know what
the end goal is there's a huge gap there
and it can feel overwhelming the key to
this is if we want to be very concrete
we should probably focus on actions and
I'll use Fitness as an example because
it translates to everybody whereas you
know people's circumstance is different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay great but to sustain that
behavior or even to make the the
behavior pleasureful and to give you
energy the key is to subjectively reward
those steps so it's not going to be
let's say I go out and I run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself this is the good part this
is the part that gives me energy and
I'll be very surprised if people don't
actually feel like they could continue
further so it's a journey of a Thousand
Miles starts with a single is made up of
you know single steps but the key is to
reward the harder steps not the easier
ones and not the ones where you get the
thing that you want there's a process
I'm going through right now where I'm
trying to write a book and it's hard
it's hard and I was told that the harder
it is the better I'm probably doing it I
was like great and my editor is ready to
kill me and because I'm slow and I and I
know and I'm a very slow person I I
drive people crazy I'm like glacially
slow because science is slow and I like
to get things right I want to rush it
yeah I like to get things right but I'm
very proud of the fact that everything
we've publish I can stand behind it was
the best we could do with the tools at
the time and I just know that when I
look back on a writing career or
scientific career I want to be able to
say you know every Journal we put in was
Rock Solid everything was Rock Solid we
had fun doing it the relationship so I
go slow yeah but as a consequence what
I'm finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days I'm I'm I think social media is
great I teach Neuroscience on social
media because I think it's important to
do public education distraction too but
it's incredible and it's it's incredible
how much time and energy it can take so
what I've started doing now is I turn
off my phone and I lock it unsafe and I
experience extreme anxiety right it's so
weird why is that is it because it gives
you so much dopamine that when you're
not having it well this is scary because
I actually think
um brief anecdote on the weekend I was
driving there's a kid that I mentor and
I picked up my phone I was texting while
I was driving and he said to me it was
really embarrassing for me he said you
know I I wish you wouldn't text while
you drive and I put it and I put it down
and I realized this is crazy I know that
I that my life and his life is far more
important and the lives of the people
around me are far more important than
any text message which means I wasn't
think doing it rationally it's just pure
reflex at this point so I was I don't
think I'd pick up the phone because I'm
I don't even know what I'm looking for
there anymore it's just become reflexive
so
for me lately the longer I can keep that
phone in a safe and right on a grant or
my or this one okay what I tell myself
is the agitation is good I'm it's at
least I'm not doing that and then I find
that as I start to write and I get into
the process I start feeling good about
it and I I'll pause and say okay I I
have control I have ultimate control
over my behavior I can put that thing
away there might be a nuclear war out
there and I'm just doing this anyway I
have control over my thoughts my
feelings and behavior so I tell myself
that and then I find I have immense
energy and all I want to do is write and
I kind of tunnel into the process wow
and I think that sometimes people need
to write these things out for themselves
so it's really concrete I think some
people are so unskilled at subjective
rewards that writing it out is really
powerful so what would you write out for
yourself as a subjective reward for this
experience as long as I'm writing I'm on
the right path as long as I'm not
writing I'm looking at my phone I'm not
on the right path because for me the the
two or three things that are most
important for my career are writing
grants working on this book manuscript
and writing scientific manuscripts I
mean there are other things anything
else that you're not doing is is holding
you back from doing that that's right so
you need to be focused Center Mass
forward on doing those things that's
right so I don't do any jumping around
power poses things like that I will use
tools to kind of ramp up my dope I mean
there are certain songs that are really
embedded in my emotionally my emotional
then they'd go back to you know when I
was a you know wild you know
skateboarding punk rock teenager that
will get me fired up and though I think
there's real utility that's pure
dopamine I'm really glad you mentioned
the diaphragm diaphragm of course being
this muscle inside of all of us at least
all mammals that works all the time to
move our lungs because all the cells in
our body need oxygen of course we gotta
get rid of carbon dioxide it does that
but it's done reflexively but we can
also take voluntary control over it I
want to just mention about the diaphragm
why it's so important for what were
these State changes is that a lot of
people talk about the vagus nerve and
all this stuff the Vegas and these
connections between the brain and this
vagus nerve or the gut
it's what gets activated when you're
really full and you eat a big meal and
you feel relaxed those are great but
it's very slow
the diaphragm is skeletal muscle just
like your bicep just like your tricep
just like your quadricep it is the only
internal organ except maybe a couple
muscles in your throat that are actually
skeletal muscle meaning it was designed
to be voluntarily moved and the
diaphragm isn't just designed to move
your lungs it also sends a signal
through the so-called phrenic nerve back
to the brain to inform your brain about
the status of your body so when you
breathe fast deliberately the reason you
feel kind of an elevated sense of
alertness is because yeah there are
chemicals secrete but mostly because the
phrenic nerve is firing off it's telling
you hey the body's moving we're really
running now even though you're
stationary in a chair if you're doing
breathing or if you're breathing very
slowly and rhythmically right box type
breathing or you know slow slow
breathing your diaphragm is telling your
brain hey we're calm we're good and you
calm down very quickly on the order of
seconds and so once you start tapping
into this you start realizing okay
movement of the body was designed to
inform the brain pain of where to be not
just the brain telling the body and how
does the body communicate with the brain
through the phrenic nerve from the
diaphragm so my lab is really pursuing
two questions and this is still being
worked out so I just want to highlight
that it's still in progress
but certain patterns of breathing will
calm you very much like entering a
hypnotic State and so you have a subset
of neurons in your brain stem that are
responsible for sighing is it you have a
subset of neurons in your brainstem
responsible for for coughing subset of
neurons responsible for laughter and a
subset of neurons in your brain stem for
sign this was a paper published in
nature this is a real thing these
neurons are every so often and your dog
does this too you inhale twice
and then you exhale long
now that double inhale best done through
the nose on the inhales and then long
exhale through the mouth activates these
PSI neurons that trigger the so-called
calming reflex the parasympathetic arm
of the nervous system so we have a
hard-wired mechanism a set of neurons
connection to the diaphragm and Back
Again from the diaphragm to the brain
that was designed to activate calm and
when people ask me how should I breathe
to calm myself down I always say double
inhale through the nose followed by
exhales two or three of those will reset
your autonomic nervous system faster
than any other mechanism we're aware of
because it's really capitalizing on a
set of neural circuits now once you're
calm you say well how do I get into
plasticity states there you want to go
the other direction that's going to be
inhaling a lot more than you exhale
you're going to be driving in more
oxygen than you are breathing out
generally carbon dioxide and that will
lead to states that are kind of more
elevated this is typical of things like
tumor breathing Wim Hof breathing
Kundalini breathing and when people
enter those States
their whole world changes because it
shuts off the frontal cortex it really
this is why sometimes people pass out or
they feel like they want to get up and
move you know you get some odd behavior
when you're doing this kind of thing so
the key is if you want to access states
of heightened plasticity let's say you
want to learn faster or you want to be
more
um you want to bring more out of some
physical training that you're doing the
key is to apply those principles first
you need to focus you need to bring
yourself to that heightened state of
alertness you can breathe to do that so
this would be superoxygenated breathing
then you want to drop into a state of
calm and you do that by these a couple
maybe two or three rounds of inhale
inhale exhale inhale inhale exhale and
then now your brain is in a state we
believe this is still again being worked
out in Labs like mine and David's that
then you're in a state for heightened
learning because you're in a state where
neurochemicals like acetylcholine are
going to be at levels that are higher
than they typically would be things like
noradrenaline slightly higher than they
typically would be but not in a
discombobulated way in a very regulated
way and the cool thing is you're
regulating them so you could argue you
know earlier we were talking about
subjective emotions and thoughts and all
these things but one thing that's
absolutely concrete is breathing I
always think of physical exercise
movement writing whatever singing
dancing talking those are physical
actions in the universe
then you have thought and somewhere in
between those is controlling your
respiration once you can control
everything that's within the confines of
your skull and skin once you can really
control that relationship that brain
body relationship you start to realize
that relationship is a lot like any
other relationship to forward action
it's just all happening within the
confines of my body so it's heightened
states of focus followed by states of
relaxation that are going to prime your
nervous system for learning in
plasticity just like hypnosis a hashtag
growth mindset is one of the most
popular hashtags in social media but
most people don't actually know what it
means and then again this is Carol
dweck's discovery not mine it was
discovered in a group of kids that were
doing math problems or other kinds of
puzzles that they knew they couldn't get
right but they enjoy doing them and they
perform exceedingly well on lots of
sorts of tests of that sort when there
is the right answer of course and so
what they do is they've somehow they're
wired for effort they're wired for the
puzzle not for the solution and when I
say puzzle I don't mean the noun puzzle
I mean the verb for being puzzled it for
them feels good and so we need to think
if we're talking about the nervous
system and we want to make it actionable
for high performance whether or not it's
in business or sport or otherwise we
want to think in terms of processes not
events and verbs not nouns so growth
mindset as a verb as an action item you
know a reward as a verb not just as a oh
you're going to just pat yourself on the
back like it's no it's what you
internalize it's a process that's how
the neural circuits that underlie reward
get stronger and the beauty of of the
brain is that you have this thing of
neuroplasticity which is its ability to
change itself throughout the whole
lifespan and the more you practice this
the better you get at it and it does not
mean you're walking around talking
delusionally about how great life is
when everything is terrible it means you
might even be very stoic you might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to continue to push
forward I really believe that we all
have some superpower that reflects maybe
this is a bit of a scientific
explanation that reflects the fact that
our biology
is tilted in some Direction people often
thinks about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or I'm not a good
athlete or um whatever but it's also
tilted in the direction of something
really special so like when I was a kid
of that age I was fascinated by animals
I was just like my and so
had I learned to listen to that more I
used to hide my interest in animals
because I thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like I didn't play the
guitar in college I didn't surf I always
like like I can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know but I
think that kind of leaning that kind of
tilt towards like huh like that's me
like you resonate with something and I'm
not the first to say this I think Robert
Greene also said this like there's a
adults will often remember back to a
time where they interacted with
something sometimes it's an object or
sometimes it's an experience and it just
felt so good like it kind of Drew you in
I would tell your young listeners to and
viewers to really
pay attention to that it can seem almost
trivial like it's rarely about the thing
you're looking at or the thing you're
doing but sometimes it's the sensation
of running sometimes it's it's it's the
sensation of viewing seeing something or
hearing something because there's a hint
there and it's that it's not really
about what you're looking at or you're
doing it's that feeling like learn it
that feeling is your compass like that's
your true north because that's the
feeling you want to get to for to find
you know the mate for your life the you
know the partner for your life the the
career track and over time you're gonna
pivot right I mean you're not gonna get
it on the first try I eventually my
story of science started there it told
me right there I I felt it in that
conversation with my dad and then my
compass was all over the place and
spinning and eventually it's it's come
back I found it but getting in get in
touch with that feeling and if this
seems at all abstract I would do it as
an experiment
I would sit in a chair and I would think
about something you don't like
like really don't like and I would pay
attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body I'm not a
very somatic person I'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body I've always felt like my emotions
were my head so when people talk like
their emotions and their other places
I'm just like I'm like I don't get it
but I would encourage them to think
about that and then I would encourage
them to think about something they
really like
that could be roller coasters could be
music could be get specific and to get
in touch with that feeling and that
feeling is your guide that feeling is
your compass because the nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will Orient toward the things that it's
best equipped to do it really will
and I really animals do this naturally
my Bulldog Costello never tries to be a
different kind of dog he never fetched
once first time I threw the ball he
walked to the ball he sat down with the
ball he destroyed the ball because
that's what Bulldogs do you know throw
to a retriever they bring it back
because the brain of the retriever is
wired to feel good by retrieving and the
brain of the Bulldog is good to feel
good by being horizontal with and
pulling on things with their they like
to tug so I think humans we're so we're
similar enough but we're different in
the sense that you have something
installed in you that feels right and
getting in touch with that feeling is
key and you're not and I should tell
that there's no you're not going to get
it right away this is a practice you
learn like shooting basketballs or or
math you do it over and over so that but
if you get started young at eight or
nine oh my goodness great and if you do
it when you're 12 or even if you're 60
and you do this you'll find that pretty
soon you start steering in these
directions and I I do believe it's a
nervous I think our it's a neural
there's a real physical substrate for
this it's not mysticism that beliefs are
attached to a set of rewards so what now
the dopamine system is exceedingly
powerful because dopamine is is a kind
of a dumb molecule it has no brain of
its own it's just a it's just a molecule
right it's just a chemical but when
dopamine is released in our brain
we first of all it tends to orient us
towards
goals in the outside environment it's
the it's the molecule not just a reward
but of motivation and when we release
dopamine we tend to see the world in
terms of external goals and so you can
imagine now if there's a process built
up inside us where our thoughts are
causing
dopamine release and dopamine is shaping
what we see as rewards what we perceive
as Rewards
that can be wonderful or terrible
depending on how that's harnessed so let
me understand this when we have dopamine
[Music]
triggered in our body it's attached to
because it's attached to some type of
belief we're going to continue to say
this feels good that's right so let me
keep thinking this way and viewing the
world this in this way because it's
going to keep making me feel good that's
right physically that's right wow even
if it's
there's a fact or Not facts
scientifically true or not we're harmful
to other people or harmful to yourself
if it makes you feel good you might
stick to that belief that's right so a
good example with dopamine is it with
anytime thinking about science and
Neuroscience in particular thinking at
the extremes can be kind of useful so
people who are very depressed who see no
possibility in the world if you talk to
a depressed person every response they
give is going to be but it's not going
to work out they are absolutely certain
that things are going to turn out bad
and there's a benefit for having that
belief and they're entrenched in it they
may actually be rewarding that somewhat
although typically depressed states have
very low dopamine at the opposite
extreme is Mania when people are in a
manic phase dopamine is very high we
know this and they see possibility
everywhere and there's certain things
are going to work out they they will
spend money they don't have they'll
create relationships they don't have
time and energy for they will overdo
everything and so somewhere in the
middle is this healthy range where where
can where we realize that how we view
the world is shaping the release of
these chemicals and I do believe this
happens when we have positive thoughts
we we get a lift if we if we can get a
lift from our positive thoughts
and then dopamine itself puts us in
relationship with the outside world such
that we view the outside world as having
more possibility that is going to put us
into forward momentum they're good there
are a lot of studies to support that
when dopamine is low we tend to see very
little possibility in the world and so a
positive thought triggers
forward movement potentially yes yeah so
positive thinking which a lot of people
will say well that's just positive
thinking it doesn't work some people say
well be positive think positive others
are saying that doesn't work
well with science I'm hearing you say it
gives you a little bit of a lift
absolutely the the key with positive
thinking it is that it has to be honest
it it can't be I've already won you know
I don't have an Olympic gold medal if I
could tell myself I'm gonna get one
tomorrow but I just don't have the
skills so that's not going to release
dopamine in my system how do you know
it's honest if you're in a depressed
state and you don't believe that you are
actually better off than where you're at
the key is to attach the so one thing to
understand is that dopamine release in
the brain is always subjective there's
no experience that that says uh that has
unique domain over dopamine release that
will only allow dopamine release so
if it's very subjective so if I say to
myself
I'm going to get into the process of
doing something we have a new year
coming up so there'll be a lot of
resolutions soon the it's not about if
you attach the dopamine release to the
process of effort or goal setting itself
you'll have more energy to be an effort
and then if you can attach dopamine
release to the belief that you're at
least heading in the right direction
you'll have more energy to keep going in
the right direction people make the
mistake of thinking that
the the positive thought process should
be attached to the finish line
it's not about thinking of already one
it's not about being delusional it's
about thinking that your training is
going to take you to the finish line and
so it's about moving that mental Horizon
and More close but more closely and then
triggering some sort of positive
internal representation of what you're
doing meaning thinking positive and
people this is usually where I get
stopped and people say wait but it
sounds so subjective tell me exactly how
to do it but here's the keyboard it's
it's supposed to be subjective this is
for you it's true yeah everyone needs to
figure out what allows them to continue
to be in forward momentum what allows
them to constrain the world of
possibilities
and to go after goals and how often to
self-reward because but the key is the
self-word because if you start only
pursuing external rewards that's when
you are no longer in control of your
dopamine system because you're relying
on actually something physically
happening in the physical world not
internal that's right and let's be
really really honest and burst the the
bubble that I feel like should have been
burst a long time ago which is yes
everybody including me it is possible
that you can do everything and still
fail no one wants to say that but the
way that you ensure against that is to
attach reward to the effort process
because the dopamine molecule creates a
sense of certainty and you're not trying
to create certainty about the final
outcome you're trying to create
certainty only about the next outcome
that's enroute to the final outcome the
next action you want to think about
Milestones yes and so people set out
with oh I'm gonna I'm gonna write the
Great American a novel or I'm going to
you know get the IPO and of course
that's an important you need to have a
sense of what the Finish Line would
actually look like but the more that one
can attach this subjective release of
dopamine process to the intermediate
steps through positive thinking and
action positive thinking and action the
the higher that probability goes toward
in science we say there's a probability
of zero to one the higher that
probability goes to one which is
certainty now
everyone knows in the back of their mind
that there is no absolute certainty when
I hear about you know athletes or
Fighters I was certain I was going to
win we all know that there's a point
zero zero zero zero zero doubt
in everybody right point zero zero
whatever that is now for some people
they might be able to push that number
way way out but certainty about outcome
is actually a form of delusion certainty
about Romania yeah that's right that's
right you see this in Mania and that's
why people start engaging their behavior
online this is going to happen that's
right the silver lining in this is that
when you create certainty about outcomes
you know you can control
you take over this neurobiological
system and you create almost certainty
that you will complete the process to
the end goal
perfectly how do you get motivated well
one way to do that is if you are good at
subjectively attaching dopamine to the
pursuit just knowing okay I really am
hungry for this I'm just I'm going to
tell myself that you know making you
know making it one percent of the way is
a success and I'm going to keep going
and I'm going to keep ratcheting on and
that's great if you can do that but for
people that can't do that understanding
this relationship with the pleasure pain
balance can be more powerful just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier of the
whole process of pursuing more dopamine
and then the other aspect of it is that
anytime that we're leaning into action
you know it has the the possibility of
being an amplifying process or a
depleting process and the key to that is
making sure that you're balancing the
dopamine and epinephrine systems you
know epinephrine being this molecule of
universal currency of energy output
could be out of hate or it could be out
of love epinephrine doesn't care and
actually dopamine doesn't care none of
these systems care about us they just
work underneath our sub underneath our
conscious control but when you start to
understand that hitting the gas pedal is
great but hitting the gas pedal and then
coming off the gas pedal a little bit
you can kind of sit in a more relaxed
RPM actually allows you to go much
further I think that people leaning into
action is terrific I always say you can
either be back on your heels flat-footed
or forward Center of mass the best
situation is actually to be
right upright but just know that you can
be forward Center of mass at any point
and you know that to take it back to sex
and reproduction because it's a Salient
Example The Arc of of sex is very
interesting when because when you think
about autonomic arousal it turns out
that the the arousal stage of sex
actually involves release of dopamine
but is what we call parasympathetic
dominant it's actually has to be relaxed
enough
in order to occur okay everyone can read
between the lines on this
orgasm is actually a
I won't say full-blown it's a it's a it
is a sympathetic nervous system driven
response it's identical to the stress
system it's driven by the same neural
circuits as stress and then what comes
afterward
the parasympathetic system goes back up
again it's that deep relaxation so why
do I say this not to talk about sex to
be you know to to serve as a highlighter
but rather our species arrived here
because of this dance between arousal
and relaxation arousal and relaxation
and one thing we can say for sure about
every human being that's alive now is
that their parents at least once
mastered this dance of relaxed but not
end excited but not too excited then
really excited and then relaxed that
dance was Mastered by all of our parents
and that's what delivered us here to
some extent and so I what this means is
that all the neural circuits from the
ones that led to our conception to the
ones that lead to us pursuing goals have
this balance there's almost like a like
a seesaw right there's activation and
calm activation and calm and it's that
Dynamic process that's important to
master in every Endeavor so we use sex
as an example but in pursuit of goals
you have to learn how to pursue
short-term goals and like the goals
within the day make a cup of coffee and
go and long-term goals and when I said
dopamine is what's setting the your time
perception it's an Interval Timer
what you're saying is it's like the two
marshmallow experiment done at Stanford
defer the dopamine
and actually if you can turn the
weighting into the dopamine and then you
can extend out the reward for you know
waiting for the second marshmallow 15
minutes later et cetera Etc and there
are many many examples of this in the
Psychology and Neuroscience literature
and I would say finally in 2020 we
finally as a field got a clear idea of
how dopamine is really working because
before it was all about
work dopamine hit right sex gives you a
dopamine hit the internet gives you a
dopamine yet what we didn't realize is
that repeated engagement with these
things leads to dopamine depletion and
that the pain and pleasure balance is
always at work both those things
breathing and vision also run in Reverse
meaning if we change our pattern of
breathing we change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bi-directional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands but as well it runs in both
directions if we expand our view of the
world literally Force our our visual
field or just it's very easy actually
you can do it no matter where you are
right now if you just try and expand
your visual field not by looking around
or moving your head or eyes but by
trying to see yourself in the
environment that you're in so you
literally dilate your views you could
see the ceiling in the floor and the
walls if you're inside or if you're
Outdoors seeing as big an aperture of
your visual field or your visual
environment as possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal State towards stress
this is why when you go to a a Vista or
you view a horizon it's very relaxing
because you naturally go into panoramic
vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at computer or
a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal State
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or Obsession or Fascination but the
important thing to realize is that both
vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal State of Mind and Body and
it runs in both directions our internal
state that could be triggered by a text
message or hearing something that
somebody says tries changes in our
breathing and our vision but our
breathing and our vision can also Drive
changes in our internal State and so
that article in Scientific American was
a discussion about how we can leverage
the visual system and the respiration
the breathing system in order to take
control over our internal State because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal State determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel like we're having a hard time
falling asleep or we're having a hard
time focusing for instance it also
determines how we batch time how we
analyze where we are in the world in
terms of our lifespan a good example
this would be when we are very stressed
we find sliced time this is why when
people are in a car accident or
something they might report that things
were in slow motion they're actually
your frame rate increases whereas when
you're very relaxed your frame rate
slows down and when we are relaxed we
get so-called perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or I can place the stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to how our nervous system
works is that we are constantly placing
our experience both our immediate and
past experience as well as our
anticipation of the future into some
sort of larger context and our visual
system literally how we are viewing the
world at that moment dictates how we
create perspective in terms of states of
Mind sounds a little bit abstract but
it's actually it boils right down to
Optics of the eye and very concrete
things like how you move your eyes and
how you view the world an ability to
control your levels of stress in real
time is extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and Neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down this creates more space in your
thoracic cavity and your heart actually
gets a little bit bigger as a
consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down
a signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up in other words inhaling speed
your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity as a consequence
blood flows more quickly through that
smaller volume the sinoatrial node
registers that and sends a signal to
your brain and the Brain sends a signal
to slow the heart down so in other words
inhaling speeds your heart rate up
exhaling slows your heart rate down so
if you want to speed up your heart rate
and be more alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense if you want to
calm down you can do that quickly by
making your exhale slightly longer than
your inhales or making them more
vigorous
this doesn't require any breath work
this is something that you can do in
real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase It's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
HRV but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time this is what people from elite
special forces can do they know how to
make small
simple
physical steps in the real world that
allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
Horizon in very close and so if you can
move the Horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that you
essentially are where you were before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything to what
extent does our subjective narrative the
story the story We Tell ourselves
actually means something for the body
and to what extent does the body
actually mean something for the
subjective narrative so this gets into
some areas of work that we're doing now
and so I do want to highlight that it's
ongoing work but I think you know the
old narrative meaning a few 10 years ago
was that if you're feeling depressed
just smile well if that worked right we
would have a lot less depression than we
see out right the reason I call it a
brain body contract early on is that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so you know the
idea that when we're depressed we tend
to be in more defensive type postures
when we're feeling good we tend to be in
more like relaxed and extended postures
all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that I'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going that's how
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective there is one way in which
subjective thought and deliberate
thought is very powerful Over States of
mind and body to answer your question
can you think your way out of the ice
bath being cold so a couple things that
are important first of all just to go a
little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now I can
say okay have a thought that just decide
to write your name and you're you can do
that I'm going to decide to write my
name and you can do it so that's a
deliberate thought which says that you
can introduce thoughts so I think it's
very hard to control negative thoughts
directly by trying to suppress them
generally they tend to just want to
continue to geyser up all the time but
we can introduce a positive thought
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you think that
your thoughts have something to do with
your future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create
Your Destiny and you think 60 to 70 000
thoughts in one day and ninety percent
of those thoughts